[Music]
Buhler hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to and
welcome to the first week of nostalgia
week and you know what that means you
look around in all the stores and what
do you see since October September
Halloween and also a little bit of folk
rock okay okay stay focused
unlike retail stores that means certain
things are going to be out and about
which is bats spiders monsters and of
course The Nightmare Before Christmas
hell they practically have their own
section why because it's become a staple
of the holiday everybody immediately
goes to this imagery when selling
Halloween merchandise even more than
popular horror films and sometimes even
classic horror films kids are now
growing up looking at Jack Skellington
Sally oogie-boogie and so forth before
they even see the movie it's like seeing
Dracula everywhere before you see the
movie Dracula it's kind of become a
phenomenon even Disney theme parks
changed their Haunted Mansion ride to
the Nightmare Before Christmas right and
on top of it the Deuter on Halloween and
Christmas that's no small feat that
takes a lot of work it's crazy how
popular this film is which is why it's
funny when someone who hasn't seen the
film finally checks it out after all
that build-up what's usually their
response
that was you all know what I'm talking
about heck maybe you're one of these
people that experienced it
someone who saw Nightmare Before
Christmas thinking it was gonna be
amazing and discovering something not
awful but not what you expected as this
popularity grows more and more so does
the crowd of people with question marks
over their heads that just don't
understand it at all so like a lot of
these people I have to ask the question
is Nightmare Before Christmas really
that great so many people year after
year shrugging confusion about why this
film is as popular as it is is it
something they're missing where is
another case of nostalgia goggles
clouding an idea that wasn't anything
that's special well the first thing to
keep in mind is unlike a lot of other
popular films that many people claim are
overhyped this one didn't start out as a
hit that is to say it wasn't a failure
either it did all right at the box
office but the reaction most people had
when they first saw it was similar to
what many people have today and part of
the reason for that back then is
actually kind of the reason today
animated films have come a long long way
this is the time when Beauty and the
Beast Aladdin mascot phantasm and many
other films were upping the ante and how
mature animated films could be TV was
following the same pattern many of them
were trying to entertain adult as well
as children and like I said you could
argue that films and TV are doing that
even today which is why something like
Nightmare doesn't seem to fit the mold
it's not an especially grown-up story
with grown-up writing or grown-up humor
it's actually super simple checks
Killington the ruler of halloween land
wants to take over Christmas so he can
do something new so he learns to
appreciate what he has well okay that
sounds fine for a little child but why
is it still being seen on clothes shot
glasses and other adult merchandise if
it doesn't seem very adult
how come adults are eating it up well
maybe part of it is that the idea is
unbelievably creative and invites you
into an unbelievably creative world
and on top of that simplifies what is
essentially kind of a hard concept to
explain holidays having their own world
and such yet it explains it in a way
that everybody can understand it's kind
of tricky to do but big deal so it
executes an idea very well that doesn't
necessarily mean that has deeper
engaging characters the dialogue from
this movie is beyond basic curiosity
killed the cat you know I know how long
did it take you to write that one but in
trying to understand why people could
possibly enjoy that kind of writing can
you think of other films and shorts that
had similar writing immediately what
comes to my head or holiday classic like
the Grinch
Charlie Brown the rankin/bass stuff and
so forth all specials that have that
kind of cheap quality to them but also a
strange kind of honesty there's a sense
that they try to keep it simple because
they don't want to lose the special
feeling of the holiday in all these
specials the holiday is what's at the
forefront even before the characters and
story that's always the number one focus
and that's why we always watch them
around this time of year this one is
very similar except unlike the others it
does it with two holidays and on top of
that there are two holidays that are so
polar opposite you'd never think to
combine them together but they did and
they mesh surprisingly well
in that they're not supposed to mesh
well again the message that should be
made very clear but as you can see it's
such a weird complicated set up that it
almost has to be kept simple these kind
of specials hold up because the words
and ideas they use are brief and short
but also important people seem to
appreciate both holidays here because it
shows what happens if they were to be
mixed together so teaches you to
appreciate everything its own unique way
one at a time but truthfully that's not
the only lesson it's also about not
taking something for granted and
appreciating the simple joys of what you
have again simple joys many great
stories about simple joys are told in
simple ways and this one is no exception
it doesn't constantly explain the
meaning
the holiday it just lets you experience
it even jack obsesses over what the
meaning of Christmas is and then he
realizes it can't be explained it just
has to be felt just because I cannot see
it
does it mean I can't believe it and
everything from the breathtaking visuals
to the catchy as hell songs to the very
easy to grasp characters reflect that a
good example of something similar is
Batman this character has been around
for years has been represented as both
complex and simple but it comes from a
place everyone can understand Bruce
Wayne lost his parents and he wants
revenge it's such a simple idea you get
right away yet there's been so many
variations of it some childishly lights
some disturbingly dark Nightmare Before
Christmas is one of those ideas that
could and in some respects is being
retold it's one of a kind but there can
also be variations there are plays
concerts and musicals that all give
their own unique spin on the source
material heck maybe years from now will
give variations even more different than
the ones we're used to maybe there will
be ones with more adult jokes more
complex ideas and more twists and turns
it can do this because it comes from a
very simple yet identifiable source I
think that's what people relate to in
the story not just the creativity of it
but the simplicity of it
this is a movie that is very basic but
so is Rudolph and Christmas Carol I'm
very punking these are stories that
anyone of any language can understand
and enjoy so while it's very easy to see
why someone wouldn't get into something
so seemingly simple it's also very easy
to see how someone would not only has
this given birth to a new movement of
creepy stop-motion movies for kids
they're still being made years later but
they're allowed to tell stories that can
be timeless and not have to throw in
catchphrases to get a crowd this is
where a lot of that started and even
though it clearly took influence from
several other holiday specials it's
still its own unique vision you take any
still from this movie and nobody would
mistake it for grandeur frosty or
anything like that they immediately know
it
Nightmare Before Christmas that's how
strong and impact it has any frame is
immediately recognizable so even though
it's not super funny or super dramatic
or super surprising that was never
really its purpose the purpose was to
create something simple but amazing
small but impressive weird but
easy-to-follow
it stimulates the imagination in a way
everyone can understand and in some way
relate to so well it'll never be a
masterpiece to everyone it'll still be a
beacon of imagination for many of us
it's a symbol of Halloween that gets
people excited because when Jack Sally
zero or any other creepy resident of
Halloween land are seen it's a clear
sign that the coolest holiday is right
around the corner and you can bet that
every person that enjoys the holiday
will be singing this is Halloween
[Music]
I'm minutes now sir critic and nostalgia
Wien has just begun coming next week
Stephen King is back with dreamcatcher
I'll be afraid of the shitweasels but
you can see it now under vessels ad free
early access just three dollars a month
to see tons of people's videos early as
well as a bunch of other extra features
check it out and get the early scoop
[Music]
you
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out this week we are doing
partnership for drug-free kids their
mission is to help families struggling
with a son or daughter substance abuse
they provide practical information tools
and support on their website and through
their toll-free helpline one eight five
five drug-free they advocate for
addiction treatment and recovery support
for teens and young adults as a national
nonprofit they depend on donations from
individuals like yourselves corporations
foundations and the public sector their
YouTube channel offers stories and
guidance to help families prevent and
cope with teen substance abuse there's
an especially wonderful video that shows
an updated version of the egg in the pan
with this is your brain this is your
brain on drugs any questions and yeah
there are a lot of questions our youth
as well as drugs are constantly changing
and we need to be on top of that this is
an organization that helps to keep us on
top of that if you look at their website
or their YouTube channel you can see
they clearly know what they're talking
about and have such big hearts and want
to do everything they can to help these
children out so please take a look
raise awareness and share what you can
with this great organization that wants
to make our kids cleaning it